.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Gewisse sagen, es brauche Mann
und Frau, um ein Kind zu erziehen.
Andere sagen,
es brauche ein kleines Dorf.
Das glaube ich viel mehr.
Wenn man in Sambia heiraten will,
fragen sie zuerst:
"Kann die Frau kochen? Kann sie
die Kleider des Mannes waschen?"
Ich habe nicht mitgekriegt,
dass das wichtig wäre,
damit man infrage kommt,
um heiraten zu können.
Ja.
Ich finde es falsch, zusammen-
zukommen und schnell zu heiraten.
Da hat man ein tolles Fest
und in ein paar Jahren
ist man wieder geschieden.
Man sollte sich
erst kennenlernen und später,
wenn man bereit ist, heiraten.
* Romantische Ballade *
Zwei Länder, eine Liebe -
das ist "Hin und weg".
* Entspannte Musik *
In Kanada hat der kleine Noam
das Licht der Welt erblickt.
Seit vier Tagen ist er
mit seinen beiden Papas zu Hause.
Jamal, hast du ihn nachts gewickelt?
- Ja.
Ich habe
hier auf dem Boden geschlafen.
Wieso?
Ich habe das Kissen genommen,
meine Beine darüber gelegt ...
Und ich habe ihn gewickelt.
Ich weiss nicht mehr, wann.
Jamal und Romain haben sich in
der Eiskunstlaufszene kennengelernt.
Seit zehn Jahren sind sie ein Paar.
Wir erwachen immer noch jeden Tag
und denken:
"Wir haben nicht geträumt,
es ist wirklich wahr."
"Noam ist hier und wir sind eine
Familie. Er ist einfach perfekt."
Jetzt kommen wir langsam
in unsere ...
Also, "Alltagsroutine" -
wir haben beide frei im Moment.
Das ist natürlich super.
Aber jetzt kommen dann die Nächte,
in denen man nicht schläft,
und die Tage, an denen man 50 Dinge
gleichzeitig machen sollte.
Aber uns geht es super.
Wir sind sehr happy.
Die Nächte sind etwas kurz,
aber es geht.
Jetzt war er dran.
Meine Nacht war wunderbar.
Auch die Familien
freuen sich über den Nachwuchs.
Jamals Mutter Gertrud
ruft aus der Schweiz an:
C'est Gertrud?
- Hallo.- Hallo.
Hallo, Gertrud.
- Salut.
Schick mal ein Foto oder ein Video,
wenn der Pfüdi wach ist.
Dann muss ich
einfach frühmorgens anrufen.
Früher mussten die Kinder
auf dem Bauch liegen.
Auf dem Rücken liegen ist nicht gut,
wegen des flachen Kopfs ...
Nein, nein,
wir wechseln immer etwas.
Ja.
- Je pense qu'il a faim.
Wir geben ihm was zu essen.
Tschüss. Bis später.- Tschüss.
Er will essen.
Machen wir eine Pause?
Mami
meldet sich jetzt natürlich viel.
Aber überhaupt nicht so, dass
sie meint, wir könnten es richtig.
Sie will einfach wissen,
wie es ihm geht.
Wir sind auch froh,
denn wir haben schon Fragen.
Es gibt Dinge ...
Klar, wir haben Bücher,
die wir alle lesen sollten,
aber zwischendurch
möchte man von den Leuten hören,
die einem nahestehen.
Ja, wir sind täglich in Kontakt.
Ihr habt dasselbe Profil.
Zeig deine Nase - dieselbe Nase.
Es ist schön, dass Noam
meinem Mann ähnlich sieht.
Er ist ja auch der genetische Papa.
Von mir
wird er die Intelligenz haben.
Aber genetisch kommt er nach ihm.
Cool.
Zum ersten Mal
bin ich wieder richtig angezogen.
Gehst du in den Ausgang?
Vorsicht,
mach es dir nicht zu bequem.
Jamal hat mich im Spital
das erste Mal weinen sehen.
Vielleicht war es das letzte Mal.
Du weinst schon wieder.
Wenn du so sprichst ...
- Aw.
Einfach unglaublich ...
Da kommt alles wieder hoch.
* Unverständlich *
Alles ist gut.
Wir haben grosses Glück.
Er ist perfekt.
Ich erinnere mich an den Kuss.
My God.
Ich hätte sie
noch nicht küssen dürfen.
Aber irgendwie
hatte ich das Bedürfnis,
als er da erzählte, sie zu küssen.
Da sagte er,
ich müsse noch etwas warten.
Ja gut.
- Nicht so schnell.
Mama, da ist ein Ei.
- Wirklich?
Ja.
- Wow.
Hilfst du mir, es zu holen?
Schnell, komm. Hier.
Oh, wow.
Ich dachte nicht, Schatzi ...
Das erste Ei.
Wow.
Okay. Achtung.
Eilein.
Das erste Ei. Wow.
Nach ihrer Rückkehr aus der Schweiz
haben Didi und Melisa
zwei Hühner gekauft.
Die sechsjährige Mayari
passt auf sie auf.
Mayari und ihre Schwester Zara
waren dabei,
als sich die Eltern
auf den Philippinen
vor fünf Jahren das Jawort gaben.
Erinnerst du dich?
- Ja. It's nice.
I remember.
- My God.
Dieter, bist du aus freiem Willen
hier, um Melisa zu heiraten?
Ja.
Yes. Yes, yes.
Ich war etwas gehemmt.
Ich durfte keine Witze machen.
Ich weiss nicht ...
- Jetzt du.
Melisa, bist du
aus freiem Willen hierhergekommen,
um Dieter zu heiraten?
Ja, ich will.
Hast du das gesehen? Mami sah doch
schön aus mit dem weissen Kleid
und mit der Blumenkette im Haar.
Und dann Dedeli mit dem Hemd ...
Ich sah gut aus.
Ja. Du bist glücklich.
- Happy. Genau.
(Notar) Hiermit erkläre ich euch
zu Mann und Frau.
Möge euch Gott segnen.
Gratuliere, ihr dürft euch küssen.
* Lachen *
The Kiss ...
Das ist cool. Ja, das ist cool.
Bei einer Heirat
darf sich das Paar am Ende küssen.
Wie heisst das, wenn man
nur im kleinen Rahmen heiratet?
Nur zivil heiraten, meint sie.
Kein grosser Aufwand.
Dass wir uns lieben,
reicht, um zu heiraten.
Ja.
Da wir zusammen waren,
denke ich schon,
dass es in einem fremden Land
besser ist, zu heiraten.
Es könnte ja
eine spezielle Situation geben.
Z.B., dass Ausländer
aus dem Land raus müssen,
aber man hat seine Familie hier.
Ich glaube schon, dass man
diesen Schritt machen sollte.
Das sind die Fotos der Familie.
- Mhm.
Das ist schön.
Für uns war es nicht extrem wichtig,
teure Kleider zu kaufen,
um zu heiraten.
Ich glaube, die Liebe ist wichtiger
als ein teures Kleid.
Wenn man heiratet,
muss man 100%ig sicher sein.
Das ist kein Spiel. Es ist etwas ...
Ein Leben lang.
- Ja.
Ja, durch dick und dünn. Für immer.
Ja.
Wir haben viel Spass zusammen.
Was auch wichtig ist,
obwohl es selten ein Thema ist,
weil wir es einfach haben,
ist dieses Vertrauen.
Ich erinnere mich:
Wir sprachen darüber,
als wir uns das erste Mal trafen.
Alles ist eine Frage des Vertrauens.
In Schweden ist es Frühling geworden.
Florence und Niklas
haben vor vier Jahren geheiratet.
Mit Florence sind vor eineinhalb
Jahren auch neun Hunde eingezogen.
Doch mit einem Schlag ist das Leben,
das sie sich hier aufgebaut haben,
bedroht.
Zwei Monate ist es her,
seit Niklas sich einer Blinddarm-
operation unterziehen musste.
Vor einigen Tagen
kamen die Ergebnisse der Biopsie.
Nichts war mehr wie vorher.
Sie sagten mir,
es sähe nicht gut aus.
Ich hätte Krebs.
Natürlich stand die Welt
für einen Moment Kopf.
Aber es scheint,
als ob ich Glück habe:
Ich habe wohl keine Metastasen.
Nicht auf der Lunge oder der Leber.
Und nicht auf den Lymphknoten.
Es war ein eigenartiges Gefühl.
Eigentlich ruhe ich in mir.
Aber dann fing ich an, nachzudenken:
"Was heisst das jetzt?"
"Bin ich in einem Jahr
nicht mehr hier?"
"Muss ich schon sterben?"
Ich war verwirrt.
"Habe ich in meinem Leben
alles gemacht, was ich wollte?"
Ich fing an ... Ja.
Aber dann
war ich ziemlich schnell bereit,
das zu akzeptieren.
Was immer geschieht ...
Vielleicht sterbe ich in einem Jahr
oder in 10 oder 20 Jahren.
Im Moment habe ich keine Ahnung.
Also rechnet man
besser mit dem Schlimmsten.
Aber ich hoffe,
dass ich nach einer Operation
und einer Therapie
noch lange hierbleiben kann.
Es gab ein paar Tage,
an denen ich 24 Std. weinte.
Bei allem, was ich machte,
sei es duschen,
mit den Hunden spazieren ...
Es flossen nonstop Tränen.
Da gehen einem natürlich
viele Szenarien durch den Kopf.
Das Einzige, womit ich mich
nicht abfinden könnte,
wäre, dich mit all dem zurück-
zulassen, was wir erschaffen haben.
Ich bereue nichts.
Ich habe nichts mehr
auf der Bucketlist.
Es ist ganz einfach:
Du darfst mich nicht alleine lassen.
Dann eben nicht.
- Du darfst nicht. Ich bin verloren.
Die Operation
ist in drei Wochen angesetzt.
Die ganze Umgebung,
die Freunde, die Familie,
all diese Menschen
sind da und helfen mit.
Das ist perfekt für ein Kind.
Sie unterstützen
und erziehen es mit.
V.a. hier und in unserem Umfeld ist
das etwas, wovon die Leute sagen:
"Super.
Schön, dass ihr das konntet."
Vielleicht
zeigt es dem einen oder anderen ...
... dass es möglich ist
und sehr gut kommen kann.
* Ruhige Musik *
Frank ist ein enger Freund
von Jamal und Romain.
Und er ist Götti des kleinen Noam.
Er hat die beiden auf dem Weg
zum Leihmutterkind begleitet.
Ich war so berührt,
als sie mich fragten.
Sie haben zwar davon gesprochen,
aber als sie mich dann wirklich
fragten, war ich überwältigt.
Es ist etwas ganz Spezielles.
Dein Göttikind.
Du bist schon wieder müde.
Den ganzen Tag geschlafen
und immer noch müde.
Die erste Amtshandlung
für Götti Frank:
Er rückt sein Göttikind Noam
und die Eltern ins beste Licht.
Die Fotos
sind für das Geburtskärtchen.
Wir denken gleich
und handeln gleich.
Wie ein Magnet.
Wir können nicht getrennt sein.
Ich will meiner Frau immer nah sein.
* Bewegte Musik *
Auf Bali
besuchen Monica und Dewa Onkel Aji.
Die beiden
sind seit elf Jahren verheiratet.
Dewa bringt Opfergaben mit.
Seinem Onkel
fühlt er sich tief verbunden.
Aji ist Heiler.
Das Wissen wurde in der Familie
von Generation zu Generation
weitergegeben.
Monica ist überzeugt,
dass er ihr helfen kann.
Ich habe Schwierigkeiten mit der
Verdauung und der Konzentration.
Das hat oft damit zu tun,
dass die Energieflüsse
nicht mehr stimmen.
Er kann die Knotenchakren wieder
öffnen und in Balance bringen.
* Sie sprechen indonesisch. *
Ich bin nicht im Gleichgewicht.
Sag nichts.
Sag mir keine Details.
Good.
Ich hoffe, dass mir Gott
helfen wird, es herauszufinden.
Ich finde es während der Behandlung
heraus.- Okay.
* Meditative Musik *
Ausatmen, Augen auf.
Du weinst vor Glück.
Ich bin glücklich.
Der Druck ist weg.
Ja, dieser grosse Druck.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
Ich habe das nie gelernt.
Kein Lehrer hat mir das beigebracht.
Es kam wie von selbst.
Wie bei mir.
- Ohne Technik.
Ich versuchte es einfach.
Meine Finger sind wie Magnete.
Ah, es friert mich
von oben bis unten. Woah.
Es hört nicht mehr auf.
Oh, Aji.
In Bali spürte ich zum ersten Mal
in meinem Leben etwas,
das mir ein tiefes Vertrauen
in Dinge gibt, die man nicht sieht.
Es fror mich immer
und die Lokalen hier sagten dann,
ich würde ihre Energien spüren.
Vielleicht wird Dewa
die Familientradition weiterführen
und Heiler werden.
Ich bin jetzt noch kein Heiler,
aber ich lasse es auf mich zukommen.
Vielleicht irgendwann.
Ich kenne den Zeitpunkt nicht.
Die Götter sagen,
wann der richtige Moment ist.
* Meditative Musik *
Ich könnte ihr höchstens ankreiden,
dass sie immer so nett ist.
Als Mutter bin ich
etwas nachsichtig mit den Kindern.
Wir Philippinas
sind nicht so strikt.
Die Schweizer schon. Gut so.
Wir gehen jetzt zur Schule,
um die Kinder anzumelden.
Noch für Ende Jahr.
Und fürs nächste Jahr,
damit sie angemeldet sind.
Bald pfeift wieder ein anderer Wind.
Wir sind jetzt auf den Philippinen
und sie müssen hier zur Schule.
Mal schauen, wie glücklich
sie hier in der Schule sind.
In der Schweiz
waren sie sehr glücklich.
Die Familie hat während der Pandemie
eineinhalb Jahre
in der Schweiz gelebt.
Dort haben die Kinder
in der Schule Deutsch gelernt
und ihre erste Sprache, Visaya,
fast vergessen.
Erinnerst du dich an die Schule?
Oh my God.
Ja, ja, das ist deine Schule.
Dein Kindergarten. Genau.
Oh my God.
Zara, gibt mir die Hand.
Beschütze mich.
Okay, let's go.
Kannst du noch Visaya sprechen?
- Ja, ein wenig.
* Sie sprechen Visaya. *
Mum Rosly
war vorher meine Lehrerin.
Wir kennen uns gut und ich glaube,
wir haben uns nicht vergessen.
Sie erinnert sich gut an mich.
Ist das der Kindergarten?
- Ja.
Good morning.
- Hallo.
Guten Morgen. Wie geht es?
How are you?
- Gut.
Und Mayari, guten Morgen.
Das ist deine neue Lehrerin.
Was hast du für sie mitgebracht?
This.
Spielzeug für die Kinder.
(Melisa) Very good.
- Yes.
* Unverständlich *
Yeah, it's for the children.
# Good morning. Good morning.
Ready? Sing.
(Alle) # Good morning. Good morning.
Good morning, how are you?
* Sie singen. *
Thank you. Bravo. Bravo. Bravo.
- Bravo.
Danke, wir gehen jetzt wieder.
Thank you.
- Everybody say: "goodbye".
(Alle) Goodbye.
Eine gute Schulbildung
für die Mädchen
liegt Didi und Melisa am Herzen.
Nur so könnten sie ihren Töchtern
ein gutes Leben ermöglichen.
Ich will ihnen jetzt
etwas Zeit in der Schule geben.
Wir schauen,
wie sich das entwickelt,
ob sie auch genug lernen oder nicht.
Dann werden wir schauen,
ob sie an eine Privatschule
in einer grösseren Stadt gehen.
Das müssen wir
nach und nach entscheiden.
I know precisely which girl ...
- Also gut, gehen wir.
Unterrichtssprachen sind Englisch
und die Sprache der Einheimischen,
Visaya.
Eine Schule
so ganz anders als in der Schweiz.
Du musst die Sprache lernen,
und ich auch.
In der Schule in der Schweiz
ist alles sauber.
Manchmal gibt es Regeln,
die man befolgen muss,
und viele Aktivitäten.
In den Pausen muss man
einen eigenen Znüni mitbringen,
und keine Süssigkeiten.
Nur Gemüse und Früchte.
Aber hier
gibt es in der Pause Süssigkeiten.
* Entspannte Musik *
Mayari, das ist genug.
Okay. Eins. Nur eins.
- Come on.
Du gibst alles dem Doggy.
- Nur zu Rexiboy.
That's not really good.
- Ja ...
Ja. Morgen hast du keine Brötchen
mehr, wenn du ihm alle gibst.
Meistens
isst die Familie Gemüse und Reis.
Sie führen ein einfaches Leben.
Have this one.
Didi ist 63 und frühpensioniert.
Mit der Rente
finanziert er das Leben hier.
Doch wichtiger als Geld sei ihm,
Zeit mit den Kindern zu verbringen.
Wo sind die Spielkarten?
Haben wir die im Koffer mitgenommen?
(Mayari) Ja, im Koffer oder ...
Im Koffer, denke ich.
Mami,
where are all the playing cards?
Ah, okay.
Schau, Mami hat sie mitgebracht.
Was ist es?
(Zara)
"Memory" und "Schwarzer Peter".
Oh-oh.
Was passiert da? Zeigt es mir.
Beim Essen
klingt der Schulbesuch nach
und die Zukunft der Töchter
wird zum Thema.
Ich werde dieses Gemüse
nie für meine Kinder kaufen.
Sie mag das Gemüse nicht.
Zuerst musst du einen Mann suchen.
Ich will keinen Mann, nur ein Kind.
Vielleicht nur eines.
Zuerst musst du einen Mann finden.
Die Familie kommt später.
Zuerst mal die Schule beenden.
Hier auf den Philippinen werden die
jungen Mädchen oft früh schwanger.
Ich wünsche mir,
dass sie die Schule beendet
und einen eigenen Job hat.
Dann kann sie
ihr Leben als Single geniessen.
Sie soll nicht zu früh
heiraten oder Kinder kriegen.
Das macht mich traurig.
Das liegt ganz bei dir.
* Entspannte Musik *
In Schweden
versuchen Florence und Niklas
vor seiner grossen Operation
den Alltag weiterzuleben.
Ich mache den Salat.
- Ja.
Geht das?
Natürlich geht das.
Ich werde noch einen Abborre fangen.
- Was ist ein Abborre?
Ein Barsch, den ich geangelt habe.
Wir haben da drin einen Fisch?
- Natürlich.
Ich mag keine toten Tiere
im Tiefkühler.
Warte.
Und was ist mit dem Kühlschrank?
Ja ...
Das ist kein totes Tier,
das mich anschaut.
Nur der Fakt, dass jeder
etwas anders damit umgeht ...
... gibt manchmal
schon fast Konfliktpotenzial.
Er will eher
nicht zu viel darüber sprechen.
Und ich hatte eher das Gegenteil.
Ich wollte
möglichst viel darüber sprechen.
Ich merkte dann, dass ich ihm
fast etwas auf die Nerven ging.
Aber ich glaube,
wir gehen relativ gut damit um.
Ja, ja.
Ich erinnere mich gut an den Abend,
als du mir gesagt hast,
ich solle aufhören zu weinen.
Du hättest sonst das Gefühl,
du müsstest bald sterben.
Darüber habe ich viel nachgedacht.
- Das tut mir leid.
Nein, du hattest ja recht.
Ich darf nicht einfach dasitzen
und 24 Std. am Tag weinen.
Das hilft dir gar nichts.
Das habe ich
in diesem Moment gefühlt.
Es tut mir leid,
wenn es nicht richtig rüberkam.
Ich dachte, wir müssten ...
Ich habe das
nicht als Vorwurf verstanden.
Du sagtest mir,
ich solle jetzt Sachen unternehmen,
die mir Spass machen.
Dinge, dich ich gerne tue.
Das fand ich super.
Du wirst das als Ausrede benutzen.
- Ja, du wirst das bereuen.
Dass ich das sagte?
- Mhm.
Nein, jetzt bist du an der Reihe.
Du hast so viel für mich getan:
Du hast das Haus gebaut,
du hast neun Hunde adoptiert ...
Jetzt bist du dran.
Mach, wozu du Lust hast.
Ich mag das, mach weiter.
* Lachen *
Hör nicht auf, Schatz.
* Ruhige Musik *
Mit Baby Noam
hat für Jamal und Romain
ein neues Kapitel im Leben begonnen.
Das heisst auch:
weniger auswärts essen, selbst kochen
und häuslicher werden.
Mit Wasser - auf das neue Leben.
Was ist das
für ein transparenter Nektar?
Gehen wir am Nachmittag spazieren?
Ist es kalt heute?
Gestern war es sehr kalt.
Ich glaube nicht.
Es hat viele Leute, die spazieren.
Noam ist das Kind einer Leihmutter.
Leihmutterschaft ist hier erlaubt.
Jamal ist der genetische Vater.
Doch es sind
noch rechtliche Fragen offen.
Wir warten noch
auf die Geburtsurkunde.
Hier in Montreal bzw. in Kanada,
werden wir beide
als Väter draufstehen.
Noam ist unser Kind - fertig.
Noam erhält natürlich
die kanadische Staatsbürgerschaft,
weil er hier geboren ist.
Weil
ich Noams genetischer Vater bin,
wird er auch die Schweizer
Staatsbürgerschaft erhalten.
Wir müssen schauen,
wie es um die Anerkennung
von Romain als Vater
in der Schweiz und Frankreich steht.
Denn dort ist es nicht legal,
zwei Väter für ein Kind zu haben.
Vielleicht
gibt es da eine kleine Verzögerung,
aber es wird wohl nicht
auf eine Adoption hinauslaufen.
Das wäre die schlechteste Lösung.
Die wird es nicht sein.
Bald schon wollen sie Noam
den Verwandten in Europa vorstellen.
Doch dafür benötigen sie
alle amtlichen Papiere.
Immer eine grosse Klappe und ziem-
lich laut seine Meinung kundtun -
das ist meine impulsive Art.
Wenn wir am Abend Streit haben,
sage ich am nächsten Morgen:
"Heute fangen wir neu an.
Es ist ein neuer Tag."
* Entspannte Musik *
Dennis Ulalayi ist vor neun Jahren
von seiner Heimat Sambia
ins Val Müstair gezogen.
Im 1'000-Seelen-Dorf kennen ihn alle.
Wie geht es dir?
- Gut, gut. Und dir?
Machst du Aufnahmen? Super. Hoi.
- Ja.
Du siehst gut aus.
Du Frechdachs.
Cool, schönen Abend. Tschau.
- Tschau. Tschau.
Tochter Natasha
ist im Val Müstair geboren.
Sie ist die einzige Schülerin
mit anderer Hautfarbe.
Doch das war für die Neunjährige
noch nie ein Thema.
Sie fühlt sich wohl hier.
Natasha spricht Rätoromanisch,
Deutsch und Englisch.
* Sie singt vor sich hin. *
Mutter Stephanie
ist hier aufgewachsen.
Welcome back.
- Papi ist voll im Fussballfieber.
Du musst dich nur noch anmalen.
Dennis
arbeitete in Sambia als Hotelmanager.
Steffi war dort mit ihrer Mutter
in den Ferien.
Nach zwei Jahren heirateten
die beiden und Natasha wurde geboren.
Der 39-Jährige
ist grosser Fussballfan.
Im WM-Spiel Schweiz gegen Kamerun
drückt er Kamerun die Daumen.
Tochter Natasha
war erst einmal in Sambia.
Damals war sie zwei Jahre alt.
Okay, ich sage: Kamerun, 1:1.
Ich bleibe dabei.
- Ich bei 2:1 für die Schweiz.
2:1 für die Schweiz? Oh.
Steffie ist immun geworden gegen
das Fussballfieber ihres Mannes.
Das ist wie beim anderen Spiel.
Ich mag mich nicht
90 Min. hinsetzen.
Früher verfolgte ich die WM und EM
jeweils noch aktiver mit.- Jetzt.
Oh. Fast ein Tor.
(TV) Eine erste Halbzeit,
die etwas lahm daherkam.
Natasha, kommst du essen?
- Ich komme.
Gut.
Wenn die Schweiz spielt,
würde ich nicht ausschalten.
Sonst würde ich sagen:
"Kein Fernsehen am Mittagstisch."
Ja, ich schneide.
(TV) Jetzt zu Shaqiri ...
Jetzt aber, ja! Ja!- Oh.
Yes. 1:0.
- Für?
Nein. Für wen? Die Schweiz?
- Für die Schweiz.
Hopp, Schweiz. Cool. Ja, Embolo.
Dennis schätzt das Leben hier.
In seiner Kindheit habe er
nicht immer genügend Essen gehabt.
Und doch fiel der Abschied schwer.
Solche Bedenken hatten sie.
So.
Das ist ein ganz spezieller Anzug.
Ich bin sehr stolz
und fühle mich geehrt,
diese traditionelle Schweizer Tracht
zu tragen.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass das einmal möglich wird.
So, Schatz.
Tschüss. Bis später.
- Tschüss.
Ihr kommt doch, oder?
- Yes, we are coming.
We'll see each other. Okay.
- Ja.
Bye-bye. Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Dennis ist Mitglied
der Alphorngruppe Ils Infernals.
Heute machen sie im Dorf
ein Spontankonzert.
Das Alphorn
hat es Dennis von Anfang an angetan
und er wurde
mit offenen Armen aufgenommen.
Auch weit weg von meiner Heimat
kann ich vieles lernen.
Jeder Mensch kann an sich arbeiten.
Das ist wichtig für mich:
glücklich zu sein und
mit allen guten Kontakt zu haben.
Seid ihr bereit? Ready?
* Sie spielen einen Akkord. *
Ton.
* Ruhig Melodie *
Man ist schon stolz,
wenn man ihn so sieht.
Dennis ist umtriebig.
Er ist auch noch Mitglied bei
der Feuerwehr und dem Fussballklub.
Ich bete.
Aber das
habe ich schon vorher gemacht.
Nicht erst, seit du krank bist.
Du gehst anders damit um.
Vielleicht bin ich immer noch in
Schockstarre oder habe grosse Angst.
Aber ich will einfach weitermachen.
Ich will Dinge machen,
solange ich es kann.
Das tun, was Spass macht.
Ich weiss nicht,
was in einem Jahr ist.
Die Natur hilft Niklas,
mit der Krankheit umzugehen.
Morgenstunden allein auf dem See
haben für ihn etwas Meditatives,
sagt er.
Ich muss manchmal allein sein.
Das war schon immer so.
Ich ging allein wandern,
ich reiste allein um die Welt,
auf die andere Seite des Planeten.
Ich brauche das.
Let's go.
So.
Ein kurzer Trip.
Nichts gefangen. Das ist okay.
Baba willst du ins Boot?
- Was für ein Morgen.
Ja, wirklich schön.
Nach der Diagnose
ist die Beziehung eine grosse Stütze.
Und für Florence
sind die Hunde wichtiger denn je.
Ich kann ja nicht den ganzen Tag
im Bett liegen und depressiv sein.
Ich muss mit ihnen raus.
Ich muss sie füttern.
Das gibt mir eine gute Struktur.
Weil man eben auch rausgeht
bzw. raus muss.
Das hilft mir im Moment
schon extrem.
Ho-hopp. Oh, hoppla.
- Jesus.
Komm.
Henry.
Achtung.
Schön, nicht?
- Und so ruhig.
Ja.
Wir sprachen davon,
noch zehn Jahre hierzubleiben.
Dann kaufen wir einen Camper
und hauen ab - irgendwohin.
I don't know.
- So der Plan, ja.
Hoffentlich können wir ihn umsetzen.
Ja. Da bin ich mir sicher.
Ich will leben.
Ja.
Ich will mit dir und den 250 Hunden
rumhängen.
Mittlerweile wurde Niklas operiert.
Es gab schwere Komplikationen.
Florence ist immer an seiner Seite.
In der letzten Folge
von "Hin und weg":
Ich bin glücklich,
sie nach drei Jahren wiederzusehen.
Auf den Philippinen reist Didis
Familie zu den Eltern von Melisa.
Der Weg ist lang und beschwerlich.
Das ist immer ein Abenteuer. Ja.
Im Val Müstair
denken Steffi und Dennis
an die Hochzeit in Sambia zurück.
Wir haben ihn beide gesehen,
aber Mami
nahm den Kontakt mit Dennis auf.
Nein, ich habe nicht gekuppelt.
In Bali kommen Monica und Dewa ihrem
grossen Traum einen Schritt näher.
Es ist sehr aufregend,
endlich kommt der Tag,
den wir uns
seit vier oder fünf Jahren wünschen.
Dieses Luxushotel
möchten sie übernehmen.
Aber die Finanzierung ist noch offen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023